congrats on your new book the art is
thank you very much you point out yes
it's it's how to start the next Google
all right we should all read that back I
want to start with all that's happening
and technology right now what do you see
is the real game changer out there we've
got a lot of headlines obviously that
have been making the rounds of people
have been talking about the Apple watch
people have been talking about the Apple
car what could really take us forward
and be sort of the new iphone new iPad
of tomorrow and it doesn't have to be
Apple well generally wearables are going
to be very interesting all these
companies whether it's Android or iOS
are creating wearables and I think it'll
go far beyond the watch if anything the
watch may have a big question mark in
that it's not clear to me that
Millennials want to wear a watch for any
reason so Apple has to overcome the fact
that most Millennials are using their
phones as watches so they don't need a
watch to increase their phone that I do
I'm glad you said that because I've been
out there saying look I don't wear a
watch I never do I rely on my phone for
everything and really what's gonna make
me change my behavior here people have
said it's fashion I'm like yeah you know
I i I'm not as big in the fashion as you
might think um I don't know is that's
reason enough to go out and buy a watch
well a scary thought I mean if it's
fashion I don't think most of these
smartwatches look very fashionable it
kind of looked like big blocks of you
know metal on your wrist the only idea
that spark my interest was the concept
that your smartphone could replace your
car key that is interesting because I'm
always losing my car keys and I always
have my watch on my wrist that that
could be a game changer emptied uh the
wearables you think are gonna be
interesting to watch let's talk about
Google you said that the book is about
how to create the next Google Google
when it comes to its mobile device
community has certainly had a lot of
challenges Android really hasn't
captured that market at you think about
google glass for example it was supposed
to be this big
and it never made it to mass-market
that's another one where I could have
told them people are not gonna wear
those things around there does not does
Google have an issue here how does it
how does it continued on vent itself Oh
first of all I would debate you that
Google has not succeeded with Android
because there are more android phones
than they are iOS phones so it seems to
me that Google has very much succeeded
we're going to do its own phone right it
wanted to actually you know have a hand
in the hardware too well I mean that's
why they bought Motorola and then they
sold motorola that could have been an
issue of separation of church and state
which is if you're trying to get all
these manufacturers to use Android then
you're competing with them with your own
android phone now that kind of gets
tricky so I can see that but having said
that now that Motorola has been sold by
google and it's no longer part of Google
was part of another company lenovo well
the Moto X and the Moto G excuse me moto
e has just been kicking butt so maybe
Google sold them to early cuz motorola
is doing extremely well possibly so what
is google do to continue reinventing
itself right now in this face well the
beauty of google is that if you have so
many smart people trying all these
things you know something is going to
succeed and meanwhile it has this total
lock on his advertising models so you
could build the case that it has this
fantastic layer of financial resources
and it's it has therefore the permission
and the flexibility to experiment and
Google is just it's just a kick-ass
company I mean think of think of all the
things we use google for and in a from
email to analytics to search to
advertising you know just because the
glass didn't succeed I don't think you
should yeah don't be worried about
limitless potential in your view google
gets thumbs up in your latest book the
art of the start to point oh I talk
about what you learned from your time at
apple from some of your own projects
what's your advice out there to
entrepreneurs people that are trying to
start the next big thing right now yes
well so first of all I'm chief
evangelist of a company called canva
right now which is a start-up out of
Australia so I'm writing it sort of as I
go it's it's this is not a theoretical
thing that I learned 25 years ago and
right now it's one of the best times to
be an entrepreneur because so many of
things that cost so much before are now
free or cheap so let's go down the list
infrastructure you have to buy servers
before now you don't buy servers you
host in the cloud with amazon or
Rackspace you have to pay for marketing
and advertising now you use social media
facebook google+ linkedin pinterest
instagram so that's free or cheap you
have to buy real estate or rent real
estate now you have virtual teams you
have to buy tools now tools are free or
cheats and what is this oh [ __ ] was the
idea that matters the most because you
can get rid of dealing with some of the
headaches that previous companies had to
deal with the idea is important but the
hard part of a start-up which the book
goes into and indeed is why the book
exists the hard part of a start-up is
execution good ideas are easy execution
is hard and this book is all about
execution good advice but you know when
you think back to your day is an apple
and Steve Jobs what would you say a is
sort of the number one thing that you
learned from him the number one thing
that I learned from Steve Jobs about
startups is that typically the customer
base the the people that you know you
think should tell you how to innovate
and get to the next curve and
revolutionize the business usually can't
tell you how to do that because they can
only describe what they need or what
they want in terms of the status quo in
a better faster cheaper status quo so
true innovators true entrepreneurs they
anticipate what customers will need or
will want or they convince the
to need and want what they're creating
and that's the genius of Steve Jobs he
didn't just revised apple too